so what we have over here making an
awful racket is it's not the original
IBM PC the original IBM PC came out in
1981 and with the IBM model 5150 but
this is the IBM pc/xt the model 51 60
which came out two years later in 1983
so this is really what the first PC was
like you had five and a quarter inch
floppies like we looked at in another
video this one's actually got a 10
megabyte I think it is hard disk and a
very noisy fan so I'm going to turn this
off so that we can hear ourselves no
need to shut it down in those days well
though you probably want to move it
without parking the hard drive now one
of the things about the IBM PC it was
relatively expensive but what happened
was lots of people realize to get it
made in time for the release date was
just made up out of cheap off-the-shelf
parts it was only one part that was
special which was the IBM BIOS which
they wrote the software for but
everything else in it is cheap
off-the-shelf part so we're going to
look at this as ever series of a few
videos will actually make our own clone
IBM PC so I've got a kit of parts which
I ordered from a company online that
makes them and they send you a replica
of the motherboard and all the chips and
resistors and capacitors and other bits
of pieces that you need to put it
together so what we've got here is a
replica of the IBM PC motherboard and it
has on it if I unwrap it yes we are
making an unboxing video so this is
motherboard for the computer completely
unpopulated and what we've got along
here of five what became known as I say
slots and this is where you put in
peripheral cards which control things
like your displays he'd have a display
card you'd have a card to control your
floppy drive a card to talk to the
printer a card to talk to your hard
drive etc unlike many computers at the
time this didn't have any video support
built into it didn't have any printer
support and so on they all came from
external cards interesting what the
original PC did have but then was taken
out for later ones had support for a
tape player so you can plug in a 5 pin
socket as used on high-fives and things
and load things in and off tape and it
could boot straight into basic well we
can look at the motherboard and we can
start to see where things go and I refer
to the actual chips we've got here let's
start with the most interesting one the
Intel 8080 CPU here we've got the actual
processor here this is a chip this is
the heart of the PC and your modern
computer today whether it's a PC or Mac
will boot up sort of thinking is a bit
like one of these you can run all the
software that ran on here on a modern PC
it all descends with this itself was a
descendant from the 8080 it's an
interesting chip because it's more of a
16-bit than an 8-bit chip which is odd
at the time but it still had what we
call an 8-bit data bus so there's still
only eight lines that could talk to the
memory or the peripherals and things so
what else have we got on here we've got
a space for the peripheral cards and
we've got space here for where the BIOS
goes we've got a clone of it here this
chip here was the thing that made the
IBM PC and IBM PC and so when people
wanted to clone it they can clone the
harder without any problems they can
copy the software off the chip without
any issues at all but it was copyrighted
IBM he could pirate it you could build
your own hobbyist style and then copy it
off your mates IBM PC when he wasn't
looking and then build your own but if
you wanted to sell it
you'd be sued for copyright by IBM and
they were quite big with rather
effective lawyers so he probably didn't
want to do that so what people had to do
is be able to build their own clone was
he had to get someone to sit and go
through byte by byte by byte
understanding how the chip how the BIOS
worked how the source code needs to be
written and then work out the
specification was and then that person
was then considered dirty they had seen
the source code they couldn't go off and
write the source code for a new biologic
was that they could be accused of
copying it so you'd write a
specification for how the BIOS worked
and then gave it to someone else
and they would read the specification I
think right I need to write a disk
driver the works like this I need to
sort this thing out you to set things up
in this way and they'd write their own
code having never looked at the IBM pcs
original BIOS to it and of course you
can see this fictionalised in the TV
series open catch fire this might be a
question that's outside the scope of
this quick unboxing video but is there a
of explaining what bias is so what is
the bias good question
the bias stands for the basic
input/output system when the computer
switches on it has to run some code and
the way is CPU does that depending on
the CPU it'll generally either start
executing code for a specific location
in memory or it'll look in a specific
location in memory to find out where to
start executing the code and the BIOS is
the very first piece of code that's run
when your computer boots up so when you
switch on a computer day whether it's a
Mac a PC any one of these old ones that
are around me they will all run their
own bit of startup code and this is
referred to as the BIOS on a PC what it
does is it provides enough support to do
very simple things like printing strings
on the screen remember they doesn't know
what sort of screen it's got whether
it's got a green screen display like the
one we had over there or you could get a
color display like you've got on the
modern one but it knows how to talk to
those things in a specific way so it
knows how to do very basic things like
read from the keyboard output to the
screen load files from the disk drive
the hard disk drive the floppies it
doesn't know how the data is stored on
this but it knows how to get a specific
sector when asked and it'll probably
have some code in there that says ok
when I start on a PC BIOS go to the
first disk that's configured and start
loading in the operating system from
there so it'll go and load up the first
sector normally on the disk and that
will contain some more code that will
then load in the rest of the operating
system and then you can actually start
to get in this case it would be two dos
which was written by Microsoft and to
IBM surprise I think they started
licensing PC DOS as it was called on the
IBM as ms-dos to everyone else who
wanted to build a clone I'm going for it
with a contentious question why did some
people say that this is a PC but say a
Mac isn't a PC so this is an interesting
question at the time the term personal
computer was in use to refer to
computers that people use rather than
big mainframe computers that people like
Dave use these are computers you could
sit on your desk and interact with
personally whether it was a sort of PC
as we know it now or more of a sort of
hobbyist Hardware thing like Steve
Furber had sitting on his shelf this
computer
build kiss was that cute formal did you
know no said tirely home design I've got
my first single has that expectrum the
box described it as a personal computer
but over time we've tended to use PC to
refer to the computer that's compatible
with the IBM that runs das or now
Windows
whereas we'd refer to a Mac as being a
Mac because it originally started off
with a very different architecture but
even that run the same architecture
something like the Atari even now that
PC thing persists even that's just
because of the size of the company IBM
were at the time they brought this
machine out possibly I think people got
used to PCs being IBM and of course the
old adage used to be that no one ever
got fired for buying IBM so people got
used to the PC in their office which was
an IBM and so it's just colloquy got to
be in that in the same way that we refer
to other things like vacuum cleaners are
referred to as Hoover's even though than
probably not made by human but by Dyson
these days ended up selling huge numbers
of them - it's a bunch of computer
enthusiasts basically and it actually
not so much computer enthusiasts they
weren't at that time their electronics
enthusiasts they didn't know they were
computers enthused s until this thing at
hid so yeah and it's not a lot more than
expected
and you know MIT's web